Backstreet Boys remember Nick Carter is
denying new allegations that he raped a
woman with autism and cerebral palsy
when she was a teenager Shea Ruth filed
a sexual battery loss in Nevada claiming
Carter gave her alcohol and assaulted
her on the band's tour bus in 2001. she
was 17 at the time her lawsuit alleges
she was in the autographed line when
Carter chose her to go to the tour bus
where she claims he forced her to
perform sexual acts he also she also
claims he gave her HPV a sexually
transmitted virus that could cause
cancer and she is not the only accuser
to make those claims in his statement
Carter's attorneys said unfortunately
for several years now Miss Ruth has been
manipulated into making false
allegations about Nick and those
allegations have changed repeatedly and
materially over time Ruth stood by her
accusations at an emotional press
conference
even though I'm autistic and live with
cerebral palsy I believe that nothing
has affected me more or had a more
lasting impact on my life
than what Nick Carter did and said to me
after he raped me
I remember him calling me
and grabbing me and leaving bruises on
my arm
Dina what do you think is the most
damaging for a Nick card of the
similarities between the alleged victims
and their accusations like saying that
at least two of them got HPV or just the
sheer number of the accusers
I mean any time that there is more than
one accuser with a similar story it
obviously helps the plaintiff here this
is a civil suit and that's important to
know that standard of proof is going to
be lower than criminal but this
accusation is very old it's 20 years old
and so she's going to have to show that
the other two people are right now Jane
does were they out in the Press are they
similar because she read their stories
you know what the HPV how common is that
you know so it's those kind of things
that he will be able to poke holes in
when he goes to defend this case yeah
it's gonna be interesting to see how
that plays out Terry Weinstein Cosby not
Lauer based on what you've seen could
Nick Carter join their ranks well yeah
it's possible when you have like Dina
said so many people bringing similar
claims if in fact he is sued criminally
and he has been here sued civilly he
could very well be another Weinstein
where he is facing the court and he is
facing criminal charges and he is facing
time in jail so it really does depend on
how strong these Witnesses are if they
are going to be able to testify and
stand up in front of a jury and tell
their stories and have a jury be
sympathetic to their causes right now
though we don't know what's going to
happen it doesn't seem as though
anything has stuck so far and frankly
you know if in fact it is something that
people are just saying his reputation
has been affected no matter what so I
hope that the truth comes out at the end
of the day in either a criminal or a
civil case absolutely hoping that the
truth comes out could not have said a
better Terry well two men in Georgia are
officially free after spending 25 years
in prison thanks to the help of a
podcast Daryl Lee Clark and Kane
Joshua's story were just 17 years old
when they were arrested for the 1996
shooting death of 15 year old Brian
bowling story told police the victim
died during a game a Russian Roulette
after putting a loaded gun to his head
and pulling the trigger but witness
accounts and a confession made
investigators charge them with murder
the two would eventually stand trial and
despite a speech impaired star witness
and a lack of forensic evidence the two
were convicted and sentenced to life in
prison the case appeared on proof
podcast last year featuring two key
Witnesses taking back their initial
testimony this led that Georgia
Innocence Project to get involved and
Clark ended up getting exonerated story
sentence was knocked down to time served
Lapeer will now spend Christmas with
their families for the first time in a
quarter Century the parents of takeoff a
well-known rapper killed in a shooting
in Houston are now fighting over who
gets control over his estate the Atlanta
rapper reportedly died without a will
according to to Georgia law that means
his closest relatives will have control
over his money and assets which includes
a large music catalog as well as future
record sales takeoff made several
mentions in his songs that he was raised
in a single parent household by his
mother and there's disagreement over how
much his father actually participated in
his life takeoff was just 28 years old
when he died we spoke with a family law
expert who says planning for what
happens to your money when you die is
important for everyone
don't like to think about it because I
mean who wants to think about when
they're gonna die but I mean I've got
news it's all coming for us at some
point
um so it does make sense to to plan for
it
and of course you can change it if your
wishes change down the line but it's
you're really buying peace of mind for
the people you leave behind and it's not
just for wealthy people so even if you
have a small estate if it's if it even
if it's only fifteen thousand dollars
if you want your family members to have
immediate access to that money as soon
as you pass away without it getting you
know blood drive by attorneys or fees or
taxes or anything like that then just
plan ahead for it it'll cost a little
bit of money up front but that peace of
mind for your family when they're going
through the grieving process of not
having to deal with these legal issues
really will be priceless
new information from a Houston Police
warn gives us more details on the
shooting investigation in an eight-page
warrant filed on Tuesday police say
takeoff was shot by two medium caliber
bullets but those bullets did not match
up with a gun that the suspect Patrick
Clark supposedly used to kill takeoff
and with partygoers not quick to speak
up detectives want to search the
suspect's truck for evidence of the
Fatal bullets police also note in the
warrant that there was more than one
shooter that night investigators believe
the second shooter identified as Willie
Bland was associated with Migos group
cuevo who accompanied takeoff at the
party his bullets did not hit anyone
according to the report Bland has not
been charged in the incident and Clark
maintains his innocence as he's held in
jail on a two million dollar Bond
Terry what do you think or sorry who do
you think has the strongest claim to
take off assets now that he's passed and
who might argue that there's a stronger
well you know it's unfortunate that
there wasn't a will because you want the
assets to be distributed in accordance
to what he may have wanted but here if
there are no children it will be given
to the parents and then later it might
be given in part to the siblings and
what it's going to do is split it up
equally unless there is some claim and
she's able to prove on the mother's part
that there was no intention to have
anything go to the father so we'll see
what happens but it'll be probated and
each state has separate probate laws
where there's succession and if in fact
she has to fight to get more of that
money she will have to provide testimony
and provide Witnesses and the father
will have to do the same thing hopefully
at the end of the day they'll be able to
work it out with having you know an
agreement in place as opposed to having
to Gold Court and argue over the details
yeah it kind of makes me want to go and
check my my will as soon as I can well
Dina did Clark's case just get better
seeing as a bullets don't match his gun
should his bail also be reduced because
of it
I mean his case absolutely got better
for both either reducing his bail or
perhaps getting his charges dismissed
outright it sounds like what the police
and prosecutors are saying is that video
footage shows Clark
um shooting in the direction of takeoff
and that's why they think he killed him
but if you cannot find the gun that
matches the bullets their case just gets
a lot weaker that's why they're trying
to get the search board to search the
truck and perhaps they will find another
gun there that could tie him otherwise
his case defense case definitely got
stronger the defense attorney and he
also says maybe they'll find a gun that
doesn't match the bullets and he gets
released and it's a whole other case
altogether well we'll see how that can
how that plays out our verdict watch
continues disgrace Hollywood Mogul
Harvey Weinstein awaits his fate in Los
Angeles as deliberations continue in his
sex assault trial eight women testified
against Weinstein in this trial where he
faces seven sexual assault charges and a
possible life sentence one thing to not
take the stand in his own defense but
his team argued that the accusers were
either untruthful or had consensual
sexual relationships with him this is
Weinstein's second sex assault trial
after being convicted on similar charges
two years ago in New York he is serving
a 23-year sentence in that case an
appeal was recently granted in Los
Angeles the jury panel has been at it
for more than five days with no question
so far on their end